there is only one solution there is only
one solution where would it lead well it
would lead to a place like here we're
going to show you a compilation video
this is Canada and London Canada and
London uh these are young people who
have lost their minds I assume that this
is sugar and or Froot Loop
induced Lord the
resistance the resistance there is only
one
solution solution for the revolution for
the revolution
father you did it's your ancestors it's
directly L to you the reason why you're
driving today is because of what my
people did the reason why you here today
is because of what your people
people you do this country you disgrace
you
disgrace the reason why you're in the
street the streets
will you see what we did there like you
hop these people up on sugar you hand
them diversity documents and then you
have this what was that a 10 12 year-old
kids screaming about inti in Canada was
the first one and then the other guy was
London but again all of these things
it's just a series of things to break
the brains of
everyone